hola muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de france 24 en español
en esta oportunidad nos acompaña
patricia ariza nombrada ministra de
cultura por gustavo petro futuro
presidente de colombia quien asumirá el
cargo el próximo 7 de agosto ella es
dramaturga actriz directora de teatro
también poeta fue presidenta de la
corporación colombiana de teatro estamos
hablando de una figura central de la
escena cultural colombiana de los años
60 y también es una defensora de los
derechos humanos desde el arte patricia
ariza muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 en español normal
mucho gusto bueno patricia casi toda una
vida dedicada a la cultura verdad de
hecho ya era una lideresa cultural no
antes de ser nombrada por el presidente
electo gustavo petro que caracterizará a
su gestión cuáles serán sus prioridades
y también sus desafíos
pues las prioridades fundamentales es
trabajar por una cultura de paz también
por un arte por la vida
por
si para colombia en el planeta más allá
del mundo o sea porque la concepción de
colombia en el planeta es mucho más
profunda tiene que ver con el medio
ambiente con todo lo que está pasando
con la defensa de la humanidad defender
a colombia pero en el contexto de la
humanidad y del medio ambiente y también
vamos a trabajar sobre todo en las
regiones reconocer los saberes y las
sabidurías de la gente de las regiones
que son formidables colombia está
compuesta por una diversidad cultural
asombrosa y vamos a hacer algo muy
importante que es la enseñanza artística
desde la primera infancia empezando por
las regiones más olvidadas de colombia
en sinergia con el ministerio de
educación y también la investigación un
centro de pensamiento que se llamará
fals borda un centro de pensamiento de
las artes las culturas y los saberes
vamos a cambiar el nombre del ministerio
no se va a llamar ministerio de cultura
sino ministerio d las culturas las artes
y los saberes toda otra concepción de la
otra consideración mucho más otro más y
más universal y más que tiene que ver
con con nuestra colombianidad muy
interesante este cambio de perspectiva y
de como misión no ahora patricia usted
representante de un arte independiente
también por decirlo de alguna manera
contestatario no popular un arte que le
abrió los telones a gente que ha estado
hasta esos momentos muy marginada de la
sociedad y también de lo que son las
producciones artísticas un arte en el
cual sobre todo la creación se
caracteriza por ser colectiva verdad no
hay una jerarquía no que baja una línea
o directrices hay actores directores
trabajando de una forma circular por
decirlo de alguna manera no esa
metodología será trasladada al
ministerio de las culturas como
principio fundamental sí porque esta es
una metodología que parte de creer en el
otro y en la otra creer que se puede
crear con el otro y con la otra
una metodología para crear en grupo pero
precisamente es un principio humanista
fundamental porque es convertir a los
actores y las actrices en sujetos de la
escena también los ciudadanos y
ciudadanas tenemos que convertirnos en
sujetos del destino de colombia en ese
sentido hay como una analogía si también
será una creación colectiva
porque escuchar el agente escucharé la
voz de los artistas que abriremos la
escena
del país para todos supernatural un poco
recién lo adelantaba pero bueno quiero
profundizar en esto porque ha sido clave
su rol en la cultura colombiana a lo
largo de décadas tanto usted como
imagino también muchísimos colegas que
habrán acompañado a lo largo de este
recorrido hicieron un trabajo que
permitió que obreros trabajadores no
comenzaran a ir al teatro estamos
hablando de muchísima gente que no tenía
quizás ese acceso a las producciones
culturales y finalmente pudo acceder a
ellas hay una conexión entre el pueblo y
el arte que es clave es cierto es
determinante es determinante por eso
hemos puesto arte para la vida porque no
es un arte tampoco aislado colombia
necesita en este momento el concurso de
todos y de todas desde todas las
disciplinas humanas que la componen para
cambiar este país para salir de esta era
de violencia y de guerra vamos a entrar
en otro momento vamos a cambiar la
historia hablando de la historia y de
ingresar en otro momento no para trillo
usted ha sido militante de izquierda del
progresismo a lo largo de toda su vida
estuvo en las juventudes comunistas
también en el partido unión patriótica a
cuyos muchísimos militantes fueron
asesinados de hecho usted es una
sobreviviente sin lugar a dudas le tocó
vivir con textos muy diferentes no hoy
colombia está en un momento histórico no
el progresismo por primera vez llegando
a la presidencia venimos de la
despenalización del aborto también de un
2019 con un estallido social con miles
de personas en las calles con reclamos
para el gobierno de bando que usted
misma estuvo en las calles con sus
reclamos un estallido social que bueno a
del cual usted hizo parte como vive esto
de pasar no de quienes se están
realizando los reclamos a quienes
estarán a cargo de canalizar esos
reclamos y quizás hacerlo realidad pues
hay varias maneras de canalizar los
reclamos de todas maneras
la peor es canalizar los tratar de
canalizar los a las malas con la
violencia con el militarismo nosotros
vamos en el caso amigo hacerlo desde la
cultura es decir entender que el
estallido social fue también un
estallido cultural y entonces darle
espacio a ese estallido cultural también
en ese estallido
hubo miles de canciones de graffitis de
otras maneras de reclamar formidables no
solamente se ve se reduce eso no se
puede reducir a los hechos que
sucedieron solamente sino si no se
entiende la dimensión cultural de la
protesta también y bueno hablemos otros
aspectos de la cultura que no dejan de
ser parte de la cultura problemas
culturales le voy a mencionar algunos
patricia homofobia racismo violencia de
género como decíamos hacen parte de la
cultura de muchísimos países
lamentablemente que se puede hacer desde
el ministerio de las culturas como dar
esta batalla desde la cultura
precisamente es desde la cultura que se
puede dar la batalla a fondo porque se
trata de en primer lugar de zeng a
trillar el imaginario de la guerra y de
la violencia y reemplazarlo por la
necesidad de respetarnos de vivir
colectivamente pero de vivir mejor
vivieron solamente respirar vivir es
poder tener acceso a la cultura al arte
entonces ese es un trabajo cultural o
sea la cultura tiene que ver con el modo
de ser de pensar entonces vamos a pensar
distinto vamos a incluir en los
proyectos culturales también a la
policía al ejército hacer un trabajo
cultural con los jóvenes soldados me
parece muy importante son cosas en parte
también de los jóvenes que no deberían
morir en colombia o sea no solamente se
ha estigmatizado a los a los jóvenes que
protestan sino también a los que son
llamados para reprimir las protestas
juntos tienen la misma edad
juntos son colombianos y colombianas y
merecen el mayor respeto que merecen
convertirse en creador no solo de obras
de arte la vida es una obra de arte
también interesante desarrollaría esto
un poco la vida debe ser una obra de
arte porque debe ser cuidada como el
acto más bello que hay sobre la tierra
entonces también queremos cuidar el
medio ambiente generar una cultura de
cuidar a colombia de cuidar los árboles
los animales pero sobre todo de
cuidarnos nosotros y cuidar a los
jóvenes ya las jóvenes
ahora frente a esto que usted plantea no
recién hablábamos por ejemplo de lo que
fue el estallido social de como el arte
es una herramienta clave para canalizar
demandas
exigencias cuestiones del orden de lo
cultural de lo social de lo político sin
embargo frente a esto nos faltan a lo
largo de la historia siempre ha habido
voces que plantean una suerte de
separación no le quitan el peso político
al arte incluso llegan a decir que arte
y política no deben mezclarse no es esto
posible se puede separar el arte de la
política no no se puede separar son
prácticas distintas en la vida cotidiana
porque la política siempre busca el
consenso y el arte busca lo singular no
es que busca el disenso porque también
hay un arte que hay un arte del consenso
que es como el entretenimiento pero yo
creo que las dos prácticas desde un
punto de vista filosófico son
profundamente políticas entonces no se
pueden separar pero sí se pueden
diferenciar
no separarse pueden ser si se entiende
lo que son pueden ser muy solidarios muy
interesante esto que plantean a patricia
escribió usted y la voy a citar voy a
leer algo muy bello que creo la libertad
es una mujer que no ha podido liberarse
porque debe coser y planchar sus
banderas usted es un referente también
del feminismo ha sido la creadora del
festival mujeres en escena por la paz
que oportunidad le da este cargo para
que la libertad ya no sea esa mujer no
cosiendo esa bandera
pues quizás si la conocemos todos y
todos también puede empezar una era de
libertad en colombia si yo soy feminista
a mucho honor es algo yo creo que hay
dos prácticas humanas que tocan el alma
de la nación dos experiencias humanas
una es el feminismo y otra es el arte
entonces vamos a estar juntas vamos a
ponerlas juntas en el ministerio y en
esa conexión pueden surgir cosas muy
buenas verdad claro el presidente petro
aquel saludo desde acá ha dicho que el
cambio es con las mujeres yo le agrego
el cambio es cultural o no es para ir
finalizando patricia qué mensaje tiene
para los colombianos las colombianas y
no sólo para la gente de colombia para
la gente de toda la región que se viene
a nivel de cambio
cuidar el mundo cuidar la preservación
de la humanidad cuidar a todos los
animalitos a los árboles cuidar la vida
y convertirla en una obra de arte y
también que sepan que este es el
gobierno del cambio y el cambio es
cultural ahora así me queda una sola
pregunta para finalizar qué fue lo que
la convenció para aceptar el cargo del
ministerio de las culturas
el presidente gustavo petro y la
vicepresidenta francia márquez o sea son
personas en las que creo por eso me uní
a este gobierno y vamos a cambiar a
colombia vamos a cambiar la historia
bueno patricia ariza muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en los estudios de
france 24 ha sido un placer dialogar con
usted muchas gracias gracias a usted una
vez más a nuestra audiencia como siempre
le invitamos a que sigan informándose en
el resto de nuestra programación y
también por supuesto en france24 punto
com sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]